what is happening there citizens the
reject Nation we are going to watch the
enchanted sequel disenchanted today and
today's co-host is Tara Erickson Tara
returning to the channel hit her up I
was like for some reason I don't think I
said this in text I was like for some
reason you're the one I really want to
do this with and now here we are
together how are you Tara I'm good it's
because Greg is very disenchanted by me
exactly so it really helps for on-camera
chemistry Dream Team baby zotero you
have something releasing on your channel
in like a week or something my short
film prime your life watch it the day
after Thanksgiving it's dropping on the
old YouTubes that's good to hear I can't
wait to watch it I'll watch it in like
six to eight business days yes all right
guys well if you can leave a like that
would be extremely appreciated also uh
full-length Reaction watch along three
sync up with your own copy of
disenchanted available for a super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page where of
course we cover many shows and other
things exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch along is included
alrighty Tara and bring that back
she'll ring the bell I thought with Tara
now able to hear her own voice that
would go down it's only gotten louder
let's watch this
[Music]
this Story begins where the old one left
off and the kingdom of New York after
happily ever after after but there is
married then nothing ever happens to you
true facts that's true Morgan sprouted
up and eventually Robin Giselle had a
baby a beautiful girl named Sophia and
for one moment Giselle truly had it all
till Sophia became a pain in the ass
she was a real oh God
but the hardest part of all was Morgan
she became with that world calls
teenager oh no
that's when she saw a sign she realized
they're happily ever after might be
somewhere else
so Giselle and Robert began that quest
for a new happily ever after
should have stayed in the Big Apple oh
boy whenever you need a friend what do
you do
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow she just slips back into this role
doesn't she yeah
who's excited for our new adventure very
excited
oh that's so sorry
she's learning if I learned anything
from meeting a princess on a billboard
is that sometimes you just
let's start our new life
you know I like the little silver in his
hair
he's a good Silver Fox yes
maybe Monroeville will give you a little
magic like I had growing up
[Music]
there it is it looks creepy
at the start of a horror movie that's
not an adventure that's a landfill
land
filled with
the church stupid
oh God
I know it's hard to start over someplace
new
I did it once
once found that you just have to look at
things the right way
perception I'll show you please we
really don't need to here we are yes
[Music]
well good stunt work yeah
I'd just be like this is an annoying
theater person
all right
we'll sing as we daily unpack our trunks
will be still friends with a local deer
the foreign
be careful
look how cute it is though
[Music]
[Music]
they're just so not faced by this
I think
oh wow
this that's a dope room
you could sneak boys up here
or girls or girls
I just wanted you to have a real room
when you got here
yeah she made them promise that it would
be done
oh it's beautiful mom
calls her mom but pretty soon this whole
place will feel like home you'll see
oh babies
[Laughter]
oh my God no
oh my god oh boy oh no
[Music]
oh
those are my clothes
[Music]
do we know somebody no
y'all disenchanted AF Malvina
Monroe
I would have sold you this house but I
deal in slightly more upscale homes
if you all need anything I'm your gal
all right I know this town better than
anyone else she's like a queen around
here oh well then I'm doubly honored I
think that every town should have a
queen
so she must be like the Evil Queen
yeah
mom
[Music]
Huey Adams is so cute I know she's doing
a great blend of like she's awesome
Giselle from before and more of a real
world person it's like a hybrid
she's grown
as an actress yes I can't figure out
this commuting Point thank you so much
let's get some cream for that
oh my God what is that well good morning
well it's a miracle one of my shirts
survived oh
yay they're back
[Music]
hey wow
robber
[Laughter]
no I don't have a sword oh I just
assumed it now that you're a country
Square you'd have more need of this song
Oh no still a lawyer ah tragic how
desperate you must be to truly do
something
perhaps this will help
huh
no way
and seeing magnificent Adventures
testing both body and spirit
may do the same for you
damn none of these actors have missed a
beat we just had to make sure that the
goddaughter of the king and queen of
andalasia got one of these
what is this
it's an andalasian wishing wow
in this wondrous wishing one
we bring some magic
he's just like Gaston and except a good
guy yeah
[Music]
that's cool she gets she gets to sing in
this movie
Dana Mansell slays
[Music]
[Music]
Morgan feels left out
[Music]
congratulations
any questions and the answers appear or
I suppose in this land you just read it
Google see in andalasia the hardest part
of life is finding your happily ever
after
everything else seems easy
this world's
feels very different
it's real life
happily ever after doesn't exist it
doesn't happy is a fleeting moment
that's the point of this movie
is that a sword
oh that was great delivery maybe leave
the sword at home after all you're
riding this train over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and then you die
it's just reality man
don't be silly you look beautiful the
flowers on your skirt oh no
I mean you look fine to me but
it's kind of an outfit that gets you in
trouble it's the biggest event of the
Year mountlina organizes the whole thing
there's also games and a little fun vote
for prince and princess her son Tyson's
won prince three years in a rope even
when he broke both his legs he still won
they're obviously bad guys
hey
splitting the
they must have had an urgent selfie to
both oh this cliche just got good that's
the prince Morgan
your Tyson from cupcakes it's sort of
ignore whatever she's doing she gets
kind of in touch
imagine if she was made of mad
hang at the drive
come on
oh gotta go that's my girlfriend she's
white and blonde
herbal tea
no
hibiscus he's right oh Edgar knows
everything he's my eyes and ears
oh he is so afraid of her
let's see Giselle our town is really
just one big family
and like a family everyone has it
how did it go it was fine
hey man Tyson's into you yeah it could
be the princess
I know you didn't want to come here
but if you give it a chance it will get
better what if it doesn't we just have
to figure out where you fit in if I'm
gonna do this then I have to do it
myself all right
I actually feel like this relationship
is written really well yeah feels human
doesn't it's just not just like
rebellious breath yeah there's a new one
reasonable yeah
no you cannot step on her Turf she makes
a great friend
uh what are you doing God
vote Morgan
that is embarrassing in andalasia we
have festivals all the time and
everybody knows the prince and the
princess and now everyone will know yes
but I told you that I could figure this
out on my own yeah girl step off I'm
sorry Giselle but you can't have a table
on school property unless you're an
official member of a committee oh well
I'm sorry I didn't no well now you do
ladies
gladly
are they gonna destroy everything
[Laughter]
I went to New York by yourself elf look
I know that you want to live in some
perfect fairy tale land but we don't we
do not talk to your mother like that
my mother
she is not my mother oh no she's my
stepmother oh
she didn't mean that
I think maybe she did
so
sing a sad song it's time for it
you're just temporary
how I miss that
they love
each day I've made this pretty mature
damn
no what a lie yeah
where life can never be out
Wishing Well
my old friend
tip is back
oh
they've improved those effects
I have the wishing me what it's called
wishes
get that wand going
that's the answer
[Music]
yeah it was it's always right
[Music]
this really feels like it's gonna
backfire
[Music]
you know I'm really enjoying this movie
it feels like a real sequel like they're
actually moving the story forward in a
mature way versus just remember the
first one you know like I just changed
where I would fail yeah that's a really
strong line
good morning Giselle
oh those the animals good old fairy tale
life here we come
oh look at that glow it's not a very
good morning at all I'm afraid well
thank you have to make it a good morning
you're absolutely right friends I'll
just
oh wow
oh my God it's like Beauty and the Beast
yeah
[Music]
no way he gets a musical number too
[Music]
you're even more beautiful than you were
[Laughter]
[Music]
the quest one more chance
I wonder if this is real singing boys
sounds like it
it's all hands on
[Music]
fairy tale two eggs were murdered on my
sciatica [ __ ] talk
the wish I made last night it came true
what do you mean we have a fairy tale
life Jumping Jelly sticks we got magic
whoa
that looks awesome that is that is
gorgeous
[Music]
wow I wonder if you could visit this
place
I wish
guess Be Our Guest
all these people have work lives
[Music]
I get the fear there's like a there's
like a dark undertone
now the evil Monroe must arrive just
like there's a
because we know it's a facade and like
there's something something dark
percolating here where is she
monologia has a queen
there we go oh there we go that's a
solid look
[Music]
what
[Music]
why don't you just focus on your little
party after all baked goods are what you
do best your majesty
oh yes what the she's got a wicked Edge
mirror mirror on the wall
powerful did you not hear the question I
did
you still want to end up shattered
but it's always
you oh well he must not understand we
said most powerful not the prettiest oh
my God that's even worse it's that wand
she's been so coy about get it for me
this is weird
what do you think it's beautiful
is that Belle's outfit
the yellow one the other one the other
one yeah I think so picture R Morgan the
bell of the ball in this
huh
who cut up the outfit I think she did
she on that crazy run right now oh yes
it's like a woman thing
for everything stepmother
stepmother evil stepmother oh still
hasn't been called Mom stepmother
what happens when you suppress your
emotions and of course I want that dress
to be made of Rags people like me always
do I'm afraid that my wish is turning me
into a a what evil stepmother
wicked stepmother what come on
no no I can totally see
that was very funny
Bravo so you better on wish that wish
quick before she
oh
[Music]
don't feel so are you about to diary on
the bed buddy oh what's wrong
what's up cat
s
stepmothers don't have cute Chipmunks as
friends they have hats oh no never fear
I shall slay the Beast looks like the
ren Fair wow whoa
oh
good thing your skin is fine yep
face still looks great even though you
got I shout
no offense sir but you might want to
find another profession
I will become a lawyer Nancy said if we
had any problems all we had to do was
ask don't be a magical wishing wand
experience if you should ever have a
question just ask and I shall appear who
is that voice kind of looks like Wally a
little bit why don't you change the
world what the hell do you think all
that magic comes from
andalasia that's where this is
definitely a wish to be unwished good
luck what the hell man
so how far along are we let's see
Stepmother's wealth their wicked wicked
good oh that was well done and the last
stroke of twelve the spell is set and
nothing will be as it was before it
means you wish his permanence for all
time
[Music]
hurry it's all ready two o'clock that
means it's cool too
whoa she keeps switching and out of that
really well
oh she's this princess character
[Music]
Beauty and the Beast yeah she she's good
[Music]
what is she talking about
that she's not perfect but she'll find
something perfectly right for her Greg
like gender identity
and now she's great she really is that
like Beauty and the Beast kind of
princess absolutely hair done the same
way back in a bow this is a very
interesting Direction the movie took
maybe I could show you around make sure
you have the perfect partner to dance
with I
oh yes stick with me your toes will be
very happy you did I think
I think blow his head up
I wish
it was a toad
[Music]
oh no can she not use it
what kind of magic is this
that's any question and I shall appear
and the legend magic which means only a
true son or daughter of andalasia come
home oh thank God
this movie's having me weave in and out
slightly losing me and then occasionally
pulling me back in and then it gets your
back
the most wonderful thing happened
Jason asked me to the festival
but I'm afraid you won't be attending
the festival tonight after all you have
far too many chores to do but surely
they can wave are you speaking back to
me no of course not I
you were not to leave this room except
for chores and then only when I say but
I promised Tyson that I would be there
oh come now Morgan a boy like Tyson has
plenty of options and frankly better one
ouch
I like that Patrick Dempsey is looking
for a purpose
I'm gonna take this rope and trip
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
these movies always have some random
girls random Child Left Behind by their
parents
run away for one second we are in your
debt sir a true hero oh I wouldn't say
that thanks to you our family is safe
I'm forever grateful
why do you look so conflicted
so where is Sophia
didn't she like break open oh man she's
rapunzeling she's doing all she does
some Tangled stuff she's doing all the
tropes of the princesses who want more
out of life
than just a man I wish for a fairy tale
life and it's all gone terribly
they're terribly right
[Laughter]
get help before it's too late
you have to do it before midnight what
[Music]
this is your franchise quick push
[Music]
I have a little job for you my pet do I
get to be evil now oh yes weight so pip
is turning evil now too
I think I thought he would be the voice
of reason
it begins and why would I do that
it's mine
I think we both know that don't we
if you won't accept the offer
you know there's only one thing that can
happen indeed uh
[Laughter]
say midnight sounds about right
oh my god
oh it's like Ursula
there's catchy songs though damn yeah
[Music]
I'm really enjoying this yeah it's good
[Music]
no
I really feel like my Rudolph's coming
to life now yeah
[Music]
wonderfully done
that was wonderfully edited too that was
great that was great that's the best
musical number of the movie the first
time I was like
all right now I see why they cast my
root off feeling it I feel like she
hasn't been like that utilized it yeah
Morgan Nancy what are you doing here um
I'm not sure something weird happened
did it by any chance include a giant
hole in your Sky
Morgan a wish so big that it changes a
world wouldn't need a little of our
Magic
would need all of it every last bit you
you should have stipulated that you know
Zell just needs
spur who she
what you mean giselle's memory tree and
it's the strongest magic there is
Something's Happened
something's wrong I'm going to go find
her but another fruitless Quest but oh
foreign
what's happening so maybe if I can bring
some of this tree back the magic in it
will get her to remember that who she
really is is good I think we're running
out of time
it doesn't work
Morgan it will
remember all the
[Music]
organ
I haven't think of bad things
no childhood drama
[Music]
yes Idina
she's like a singer
she is
taking the last movie
damn she's so good
she's the voice of Frozen oh my God
that's crazy
[Music]
Let it Glow
there you go they know what they're
doing
physicals
I don't know what the instrument is but
yeah
yes
wow yes
this is beautiful
I got chills peeps me too
that's why Dina
it's my memory tree
back
I thought we established that through
the whole song okay
we've been singing about that for
that two minutes
right right
advice get a life she hates you both
great but I gotta
book
I missed the Chipmunk Morgan where have
you been okay
no actually I'm really really not can I
get a lift of course go I'll be right
behind you
oh wow
I wish
queen of monroesia
all right job done did he do anything
else it's time we end this
once and at all
[Music]
you wish
we're going full Harry Potter right now
destroy her
[Music]
I wish
[Music]
butterflies yeah
it was her fault she's the one that
should be the toad again you're the one
who let the cannon you two are the worst
what have you done whoa
[Music]
what are you wishing for oh andalasia
has to break through to remind her she's
good come on now
time to be heroes
Giselle you've got to find it within you
come on
[Music]
need a hand
the memories
[Music]
now she's gonna burn it no garbage
no
Giselle no
what the hell Giselle
[Music]
oh
this is a date I was hearing from the
first Channel movie
[Music]
all right
wait is it working is that what's
happening I guess what the heck is going
on around here
he's back
oh it worked even though she ripped it
up I guess well allowed to disperse some
type of spell Ember
science Embers of spell
Robert
[Music]
oh well that was easy it was like Beauty
and the Beast how it like he turned lit
that way yeah
but
all they had to do is check the paper
yeah rip it up you're going to drop that
wand and let the clock strike and then
she'll be free but if I do that
and Elisha dies yeah but Morgan's not
your blood daughter
die you squished it
[Music]
why don't you just wish for the thorn
stuff yeah the vines to go away and then
[Music]
what is this
her weird
tree house
ah yes
all right you guys 60 Seconds come on
now you have to make a new wish Market
no one but a true and dilation can use
that broken piece of kindling but
go for it
you are true daughter of andalasia
because you were my daughter Morgan oh
that is touching I've known a lot of
magic never
never
my love for you
the power
if you love it there inside you
and my love will be there that's so
sweet
I wish I was home
with my mom
[Music]
you did it
I do remember I had the craziest dreams
last night
he really doesn't remember anything
only the person who wields the magic
ever really remembers it clearly to
everyone else it's sort of like a dream
you got no magic Robert
I just really wanted Morgan to be happy
here and I guess I got a little carried
away
turns out we do have room on one of our
committees
if you'd be interested
I think our town
could use someone like you
I'd love that oh we're hugging
your tiny peasants are quite Fierce as
are you Robert oh so grandly oh save the
day with my sword
we have a very special gift whatever
dish you wish will appear on this plate
that's all that it does
[Laughter]
I just love you and I couldn't wish for
anything more
and some days
[Music]
those Cuties
[Music]
we did it we watched disenchanted it was
so good I got sniffly at the end because
I cried during the mom and daughter song
a little bit yeah that was a little sad
it was very good
Idina Menzel was in rent the original
cast yeah I feel like I was like that I
feel like I've got to teach you about
Idina she's the best I have no idea who
she is this is her I know her voice from
a mile away
[Laughter]
she's perfect
wow
ah the split screen scene bingo I
thought the songs were great they were
very good they were really great my
favorite one was obviously Idina
Menzel's they were all very good but I
just her voice she was the one that can
really like belt it out oh yeah she's
phenomenal that's crazy because she's in
the first one
so I was like oh dude what a cool thing
they looked at actors have an
opportunity to sing alrighty well
um yeah I I feel like there's so many
positives I I think there's some um I
don't I'm gonna do my best to refrain
from just doing like a one-to-one
comparison to the first movie because
the the first movie is pretty fresh in
my mind
um but yeah I I would say that like I I
think the musical numbers they did a
great job here because they were real
songs and what I mean by that is the
first film
and I could be wrong about this but my
my recollection of it is that the the
songs in there were were more like they
were funny you know like they were used
more for humorous purposes and here they
had real songs real songs real narrative
thrust uh and it was kind of cool for
them to embrace that instead of doing
like there were some songs that were
like a yeah commentary piece or
something funny but here it they were
for the most part like genuine songs you
know like even the song at the very end
when she's singing to Morgan and then it
is like I got a little misty-eyed as
well it was very emotional I don't think
you really get something like that in
the first film so I thought that was
really cool to advance and and to me
it's like Amy Adams it's still I love
that she did something very different
here and uh she's like when I say she
hasn't missed a beat I'm like damn she
is still she's rocking it she goes from
Evil to normal you're like what during
that whole walking toxin just like that
yeah it's a perfect switch she's great I
gotta see if that girl who plays Morgan
is the same act because they look alike
so I'd imagine they're the same one
which I think would be cool to carry
over here
um I just let me look that up really
fast
Gabriella bataccino is she the same one
in enchant she is not the same one in
Enchanted damn they look similar well
well well
still though you know it's so impressive
I thought she was great I thought she
was great she was a wonderful addition
to the to the whole movie they probably
needed someone who could sing yeah it's
true I don't know what happened to that
other girl but yeah that's it's great
that they they got she looks like it
would have been an older version of the
former actress and I I did think they
provided a good Nuance uh for that
relationship for sure Adina Menzel
God I love her so much what is it that
you love what'd you love about her in
this movie oh man it's just her well I
was so excited when they started singing
I was like they're gonna give idea
yeah uh sure voice is just brilliant
she's great uh she's a just a great
actor she's a big wig in the musical
theater world and now you know in Disney
she took over Frozen and now she took
over disenchanted is she she was in the
free I don't know it's kind of learning
on this information you're sort of
blowing my mind right now and I'm like
she was in Enchanted right yeah and why
didn't they make her says they didn't
give her a musical number at all this is
kind of shocking to me that they didn't
give her a musical number she is just so
so good her song was my favorite yeah I
mean it's like but before that song was
the one with Maya Rudolph and Amy Adams
yeah when they're squared off and I was
like okay that's the best one but the
villain that was before that one
appeared yeah I think that one
definitely hits the beat and it's also
the closing credit song for a reason oh
yeah let it glow good yeah yeah it was
that was beautiful
um to me I I feel like the first half
hour
and the last half hour are the movie's
strongest points I agree there's
somewhere in the middle where you said
you were like weaving in and out where
they followed different characters but
the pacing didn't feel totally right of
like why are we now following him when
we were kind of wrapped up in a story
Briar yeah uh that it sort of like
bounced to like for Edward and then like
Robert I think that's what it was and
then maybe back to Sophia I don't know
it was kind of a little bouncy in the
middle there but then we got back on
point yeah I thought like the first half
hour I was I was really impressed with
um you know I was like wow I'm really
into this and
it's everything before she it wasn't
like right away when she turns the world
in the fairy tale line it wasn't that it
was as we sat with the fairy tale land
when it was starting to fall flat for me
a lot because I thought thematically it
was really interesting what they were
doing of Gisele where you watch her come
from fairy tale world in the first movie
to then being learning about more human
emotions and like what a date isn't he
should just marry just someone off of a
whim you know right like find your Truly
find your true love instead of just
trying to find someone to fill in that
Gap and really get to know someone find
someone with a bond and she even learns
about anger and other emotions so here
when you catch up with her
it is I love the theme of
this person who comes from a world of
Happily Ever After can they can they
manifest happily ever after easy breezy
in the real world and so you cut to this
time Jump where it's like many years
later and no it's not I like that it
wasn't going great for her that she
can't she's not really learning how to
be she's having a hard time being like a
real world parent
and trying to come in from a world of
andalasia and then trying to raise your
daughter your daughter in the real world
is tough and and one of the biggest
hearts of the first movie was the
relationship she forms with Morgan to
see it strained in the way that felt
believable uh I thought was really
strong and and when they got to the
fairy tale world
when they turned the world into the
fairy tale world I felt like it really
lost the focus and heart of that it just
became like
a fairy tale yeah became a fairy tale
world yeah yeah and instead of dealing
with the the themes at hand it started
feeling like a sketch to me versus
really because I get what they were
because they lost the strain between her
and Morgan absolutely and they also like
the strains of uh everyday life because
they wished for a fairy tale end so I
get it but that was the foundation of
the story in the beginning which is what
I think brought you and people in yeah I
thought that's what was the realism of
it it made it emotional and that's you
know when comparing to the first one it
is that blend of fairy tale world in
real life New York City where a lot of
the comedy comes from and but also a lot
of the strength of what made it feel
like a real film came from and then here
it yeah it was just it was losing sight
of it this this the the thing with uh
Maya Rudolph the queen which is nowhere
near as interesting as the thing with
being a parent yeah to me yeah I agree
and at least the way the movie I I think
I really think it was the execution I
don't think the idea is bad like I
thought they could have done something
that was probably way more interesting
in that middle Act
of you're creating a fairy tale world
and uh you know but this is it's still
not that great you know right like it
could have been even worse which I guess
it was did end up being bad bad but with
her turning evil I think is what they
were doing right with her turning Wicked
which I kind of just felt was
I think it would have been more
interesting if she was turning evil
because the real world was made
yeah yeah like this is what she brought
onto herself because the real world was
pushing her there like it's still kind
of there and that's what I mean I think
the last half hour really brings that
back into focus and in the first half
hour is really strong but that middle
chunk it just was
it's it's like everybody's noticing in
the scene when she's like be just doing
this the evil stepmother Cinderella
tropes of just like you didn't clean
this you didn't clean this you didn't
clean this it just felt like this is all
facade and not rooted in anything real
that came before she made this wish
which is what I think they wanted to do
does that make sense like yeah because
we got very attached to like the real
feelings and they built foundational
blocks in the first 30 minutes and then
we lose them all because it's like well
now you just get introduced to a fairy
tale land where it's like because they
can do whatever they want and it feels
like cosplay yeah yeah exactly doesn't
even feel like a real fairy tale like it
feels like a little cheap and uh yeah
it's not really there's not it's not
really that funny
and they're not really doing that
interesting and it's it's just uh
yeah it lose it becomes flat and then
and I feel like they really didn't know
what to do with Patrick Dempsey they did
not they were like put them in a forest
and have a
half an amount but then the animal lock
them behind that rock and he doesn't get
to do anything and then later we're
gonna have a beast come through you
might be able to do some stuff yeah it
was like it was like can't you find a
better storyline for him to live in a
fairy tale land yeah right I think I
think a part of what made it not work
was the fact that everyone
felt that way it was like they were
throwing did you feel like I felt like
they were throwing each and every
character was obviously thrown into
Fairytale Land I understand it but like
specifically for him it felt like we
kind of are not
sure I think we needed a character to be
like this you shouldn't be doing this
Giselle you needed I think you needed a
character yeah a reason of like a voice
who was aware that these changes were
happening and that instead of being just
under the spell I think that would have
helped it out with having like if it was
Patrick Dempsey or Morgan yeah
it was going to be pip yeah and I
thought that would be until he became
the evil cat yeah it just started
becoming the thing that I thought
Enchanted one did a good commentary on
and now they're just becoming that and
and then but it was looking cheap but
then it's like but like I said in that
middle act though there are things that
obviously still really work like I when
it got to the musical number with Maya
Rudolph and her I was like this is great
yeah like Maya Rudolph is is such a
great actress and a presence and a
hilarious woman and I was like I don't
feel like they're really doing anything
with her that feels like why'd you get
Maya rude off until that moment until
that scene yeah so it took a while to
get there
um I think the Morgan's musical numbers
are like all the musical numbers
sprinkled in throughout are are really
solid and Amy Adams performance from
beginning to end is is Bravo even in
that middle chunk is is really really
strong and I think they tried
thematically bringing it back in to be
like no that that is what this is about
but I feel like they lost kind of the
engine interesting aspects of that
Conflict for like 45 minutes or
something like that like it felt like a
long chunk that was like all right we're
just watching like a a different film
now yeah and the one you've set up in
the first like 30 minutes like it would
have been fun if they had someone being
like no no no no no no and she's like
shut up yeah like you know what I mean
like the voice of reason and evil gets
rid of it but voice of reason always
finds a way back occasionally that could
have been something fun to play with
yeah it started it wasn't feeling like a
real struggle after a while it was
feeling like disjointed I'm like okay is
this more about the her because like the
whole thing with her being a a mother
was getting lost and it was becoming
about
being Wicked and then Maya Rudolph stuff
when I thought that was kind of a
perfunctory thing and not really like a
deterrent from an evil stepmother versus
like why is she fighting another
villains yeah it didn't feel like it
necessitated it that well whereas it's
like yeah I know you need your evil
villain and whatever
um another antagonist but it I didn't
feel the way they wove her in
was helping to compliment because it
felt like you had two completely
different stories and yeah there's like
a mishmash because it was bizarre like
the first half hour I was like I'm
really loving this I was like I'm I'm
really really loving this and and this
feels like a right way to do a sequel
and then it became like a sketch and
that was it and but then the last half
hour like I said uh it's like what I
like when it got dark yeah um I thought
those visuals were great
um they had a really good emotional
punch at the end and I like where Morgan
comes to realize I like Morgan having
magic yeah you know because you are my
yeah yeah because it's great you see
like that story I feel yes
which is like they sat in a room and
they were like yeah we get it let's
follow like mother and daughter into
Fairytale Land but like also since we're
playing with all these different
characters and lands we should have
villains sing a song together it was
like the it's like a great idea to be
like we should incorporate that somehow
like that's her struggle like you know
how every character has to hit some sort
of struggle but I'm like yeah but you
were already struggling with your
daughter great throw in some evil other
evil mom who's like gonna be in your way
and be a punk but did they need to give
her that much screen time I I love Maya
Rudolph yeah but maybe if it was more
about her and Morgan and Maya Rudolph
and her was a little bit more of a side
story and it was more
I guess follow the foundational block
that we said actually like the thing you
said in the beginning that she was like
she's an evil queen and she's doing this
yeah actually it was like oh then you
would have had then you would have had a
weighted necessitate her in an
interesting way in a different way
versus like they're both evil and then
end up in a villain song this is not
even like a real evil like no yeah it
was it's so bizarre I'm also like why
didn't she switch when she has the evil
song with my Maya rude off the villain
song I'm like oh it's so funny to me
that they they missed maybe an
opportunity to have Amy change to be
like singing in a villain role but then
also like oh God like maybe this isn't
right like evil again yeah
um and maybe that would have been too
weird but they played with it throughout
the rest of her talking back and forth
which I thought was a lot of fun and I'm
like did she sing a song where it was
like uh kind of at the end with the when
they changed the when she's standing in
front of Morgan and the lighting changes
which is good she was singing which is
cool but still I'm like they should have
done some play with that yeah at least
they could have made that middle trunk a
lot more interesting yeah like it was
it's a fun movie it is fun yeah
um it it's just I thought the first half
out I think it's because I thought the
first half hour was so strong and that's
why I was a little disappointed by
after the big musical number because I I
thought when okay when it turns into
fairy tale land and they have the big
musical number and it's freaking
fantastic before you reveal Maya Rudolph
coming out of the carriage with the
Queen yes uh Crown
um that that whole musical number was
wonderful and I was like oh this is
great because the big part of what this
movie's telling you is like life is not
a fairy tale and you can and she's like
wishing that I I wish I could go back to
the past yeah you know instead of
embracing the present
and I thought okay this is good because
this is all a facade that's happening
here so there's got to be something
that's like percolating underneath it's
going to break through here and I guess
they were trying to do that with her
being Wicked but I just felt like a
spell thing and not something actually
rooted in character yeah which I thought
that's what they were going to do but
then they ended up not doing it and I
was like this would have been so much
more interesting if it was rooted in the
fact that she can't handle the real
world and and people and she can't
handle like this like she seems so
traumatized by when Morgan called her
stepmom yeah and it breaks her down like
a real people break down in the real
world because of real life and the world
that we live in yeah and that's worse
it's like when this all happens it's
like oh my God I got I lost myself in
this right I'm like there you would ask
him instead of just oh it's just the
wish gone wrong you know right it's just
a spell yeah and I think if you carry
that throughout the second act and all
everything else would have had a better
dramatic narrative thrust because yeah
you know like having that aware
awareness I think helped the First
Enchanted when when there is the musical
numbers in Patrick Dempsey's like why is
everyone singing what's going on here
this is weird you know and that helps it
and I think if you instead of just
having to be some weird
sketch yeah if there was if he was that
character or pip was or a couple of them
were that I think that would have helped
it out to have like some like some type
of conflicting scene of
Giselle you can't do this this isn't
real this is bad you know and then her
getting carried away with power and
stuff would have would have been cool he
still could have had like the same half
the last half the the bookends could
have still looked the same and I just
think it would it's just the most of the
movie I don't know if it's most of the
movie Just a solid half of it it feels
dedicated to it yeah and so yeah but I
still don't get me wrong I still
appreciated the film a lot yeah I still
I still really liked it I did find that
at the end when we were saying why can't
she just say I wish for the vines to go
away and then she just breaks it with
her foot my Rudolph just breaks it and
I'm like I don't know I liked where they
got where that led them to that song
that song is worth any plot and
storyline that came before it to be kind
of Rocky and not so great because what
she says to her daughter at the end it
like kind of cries singing through tears
is brilliant I really love that moment
like that moment really hit at home for
me so I think that was like Bravo on
that but that part at the end I get as a
Sleeping Beauty mixture I'm like is
there a I don't know just it did feel
easy that moment felt really easy but
overall I really like the film there was
just a few moments in there I was like
that felt a little too easy writing wise
I feel like they maybe could have played
with that a little bit more to make it
seem like oh I didn't see that coming
which I didn't feel that way at any part
in here in regards to the the stuff that
she has to come up with her struggles
the what do you call them what is it
they put them up against I keep saying
struggles but what is the actual in a
script you put a character and then the
the thing it's like
an obstacle isn't it obstacle in a skirt
where they're like people always like a
conflict like a character conflict maybe
it's just [ __ ] obstinate you guys I
don't know you get what I'm saying
though yeah you get it yeah I get you
obstacle
that was obstacle yeah okay all right
um I I do like the it's the first one is
such a romantic movie so to see what
happens with Patrick Dempsey is a
disappointment to me yeah because I
thought they could have done something
again with like make it about parenting
why not do a different different to find
a direction of where you get thrusted
into this sure I mean many people who
grew up on Enchanted are now parents too
you know so like you could have made it
about parenting yeah and their
relationship could have really struggled
with him maybe being a voice a reason
saying what are you doing stop doing
that like I have to take my kids and
maybe Sophia away from you or maybe
their marriage gets more ripped apart
because of how Amy gets into you don't
have to go like too dark but do
something but a little dark because it's
fun yeah okay that's not happily ever
after it is that because that's what the
movies the movies is starting with
telling you that yeah that's what we're
gonna do and and they don't really do
that so I'm like okay then let's see the
marriage word they're having having a
bit of a hard time yeah I thought this
would be happily we get married and it's
happily ever after but it's not you know
and and explore that instead they do
like weird jokes with him and he becomes
like a nothing character in yes he's
really not much it was like so nice in
the in the first half hour I was like
okay dude they're doing something with
him and in General Morgan and Sophia
were always safe so was Patrick Dempsey
with one of them having a baby that
didn't even imagine they didn't utilize
them to affect her character yeah just
just the plot of of having them there
and share more at the end I get it and
then you have a [ __ ] a James Larson
show up and be like hey for the
goddaughter yeah it's like a plot the
baby becomes literally a 1B plot device
it's just like but you didn't really use
it as much as they could have to build
her character more yeah I thought they
were gonna do something that really hit
home of you know because they seem to
set it up of when Morgan says I'm the
fake I'm a fake daughter
of you know this comparison to this
baby who is probably who is born from
Amy Adams and and then realizing like no
I am a real daughter as as well like
they do that but they don't tie it into
the the feeling she had of feeling like
a friend in the middle of the movie none
of that comes back until the very end
yeah I want uh I wanted more to follow
that I just felt like they had such a
great
story they yeah they were setting up
here and I was like this is really
interesting and and then they they
didn't do it and that's the part that's
why it's kind of sucky to me on that end
because as much as there's like yeah
there's fun stuff throughout uh and the
music songs are brilliant the songs are
brilliant the songs are still so good
yeah um but I think that for that first
movie is very different and but it's
really focused and I think this movie
lacked focus and that's the only real
comparison I'd give it like James Marson
is a I miss I was like of course I would
want more James Martin I don't really
see how the plot would need him right if
he he does feel missed and and I and I
agree and for me I'm like Robert uh
Patrick he's the one who I'm like I know
you should have done something better
with him because he's necessary to be in
this movie so you should do something
better with him
um whereas like James Martin's like yeah
I wish there was more James Marston but
I guess he's not necessary to be in here
very much you know like why didn't he
become an evil lawyer
yeah like just make everybody I don't
know like I know it was just only her
but I'm like I don't know if they're in
some weird fairy tale land like lures
aren't all great right yeah
well I don't know that might be too it's
too convoluted but I'm just saying maybe
anything else for him well they didn't
do anything fun with the fairy tale land
really that I didn't think they did
anything fun with turning into a fairy
tale language right you're not they
didn't go like okay here's what the
world is like now here's what happens
when you turn into a fairy tale then
it's just it's just a Renaissance fear
it's all it turned into it you know it
did it it didn't do anything that
different right and a bunch of things
you've seen before you didn't watch like
the flip of what happens when you turn
this thing into yeah yeah you're right
which would have been a little like
Beauty and the beastish I guess but I
would have liked that yeah I would have
liked to see like okay maybe he still
has to commute to work what is that what
is that
yeah yeah
um yeah but I don't know it was fine it
was it was fine it was fun it was fun
loved the songs and the songs that like
I could listen to the soundtrack over
and over again on its own and be like be
like you know maybe I love this movie
uh but it was it was fine it was fine I
had I had I had fun watching it I'm glad
you were here
um and uh yeah but what did you guys
think did you did you love it from
beginning to end did it hit you in all
the right Fields uh leave your thoughts
down below all we can do is be honest
subscribe leave a like follow Tara on
her YouTube channel check out her short
film what's it called Prime Time of Your
Life great time of your life my YouTube
channel is under my name Tara Erickson t
a r a e r i c k s y do it people
we'll catch you all soon bye
[Music]